o futuro não é um lugar para onde
estamos indo
é um lugar que estamos criando o caminho
para ele não é encontrado mas construído
o ato de fazê-lo muda tanto realizador
quanto o destino vem de uma pequena
cidade do interior de minas
cresci com a maioria das pessoas de
classe média da minha geração estudando
em escola pública e acreditando que o
sucesso era fazer um curso superior e
conseguir um bom emprego para vencer na
vida
levei esse conceito de sucesso superar a
sério e os 18 anos para ser concluído
para um banco e logo estava empregada
com carteira assinada um sonho para
muitas pessoas da minha idade e claro
também sonho meu site
mas pra mim não era o suficiente eu
queria mais
atrasei-me o idealismo sonho de fazer
alguma diferença no mundo
lembro de quando ainda criança ganhei de
presente de natal um brinquedo um
aspirador de pó e eu quis dar a ele uma
utilidade mais nobre e transformei numa
draga para fazer a limpeza do lago da
cidade onde eu morava
mas aos 20 anos eu já havia me esquecido
da draga da limpeza do lado estava
totalmente envolvida no desenvolvimento
da minha carreira do meu potencial
porque nós vivemos numa sociedade que
hoje se conectou do sonho eo substituiu
por um pragmatismo hipoteticamente mais
e ficar comigo não foi diferente
meu sonho se tornar um sonho de consumo
passei boa parte dos anos da minha vida
construindo essa carreira tal
empregabilidade que lhe rendeu dinheiro
casa carros viagens das melhores escolas
para os meus filhos e um novo emprego
sempre melhor do que o anterior
construir essa trajetória no entanto
significou abrir mão de muitas coisas e
de estar perto das pessoas que eu mais
amava
não acompanhei de perto os últimos anos
da vida da minha mãe
não estive com minha irmã na maternidade
quando minha sobrinha nasceu não foi ao
enterro
a minha avó paterna estava em viagem
internacional quando meu filho teve
pneumonia e uma outra vez estava
engarrafada no trânsito do rio de
janeiro quando um deles caiu de
bicicleta e precisou ir para o hospital
e mesmo tendo a sensação de dívida na
vida pessoal e também não me sentia
credora na vida profissional em todos os
lugares onde estava estava pela metade
meu maior desafio nesse período foi
conseguir reconhecer a contradição que
minha vida havia se tornado a essas
alturas eu trabalhava pela
sustentabilidade como um caminho
possível para livrar a espécie humana da
rota de colisão em que nos encontramos
eu acreditava na sustentabilidade mas a
minha vida não era sustentável e quem
ajudou a reconhecer essa contradição
foram os meus filhos eles foram os
maiores mestres eles já estão mais
velhos hoje são tão felizes assim porque
eu poderia gerenciar com facilidade os
projetos dos recursos que passavam pelo
centro de cursos que eu administrava
mas eu não conseguia justificar para
eles a minha ausência e nem conseguia
ter bons argumentos para o meu cansaço
ea falta de paciência no pouco tempo em
que passávamos juntos as coisas
começaram a incomodar quando eu percebi
que o mais significativo resultado de
tudo de bom que eu havia construído era
ruim eu não tinha tempo eu não tinha
tempo pra ele eu não tinha tempo pra mim
eu não tinha tempo para aprender algo
novo não tinha tempo para cuidar da casa
minha vida se tornou uma corrida contra
o relógio
eu me lembro de uma vez em que estava
voltando de uma viagem a trabalho e
quando o avião pousou já estava de olho
no relógio que eu saber se demorasse a
chegar em casa e encontrar meus filhos
domingo e no dia seguinte saía cedo para
uma reunião
talvez tenha demorado 15 10 minutos para
abrir a porta do avião
naquele momento eu caí no choro foi ali
eu percebi que tinha sido sugada pela
tirador de fome
dali por diante se eles mente acaba
começou a cair e foi por causa da dívida
de um apartamento que eu havia comprado
pouco antes de separar a gente
hoje eu sei que ninguém é maluco de
comprar um apartamento quando está em
processo de separação mas eu estava tão
difundida de que as coisas
pernas pudesse resolver as questões
internas que talvez acreditasse que
morar num lugar novo e bonito pudesse
trazer de volta harmonia bem o
apartamento infelizmente não ficou
pronto a tempo e nós não separamos
depois da separação aquele apartamento
ficou pra mim e na verdade ele se tornou
uma grande dívida eu passei alguns meses
tentando renegociar aquela dívida com a
construtora mas ela não tinha a menor
intenção de colaborar porque o preço
daquele modo havia triplicado e era
muito mais interessante era revender
outra pessoa do que facilitar as coisas
para mim e chegou um determinado momento
eu tinha que tomar uma decisão ou
devolveria aquele imóvel continuaria
morando lá mais por 1 10 anos à custa de
medidas judiciais e eu optei por
devolver o imóvel e ao ter que lidar com
a devolução daquele imóvel tive que
encarar talvez pela primeira vez na vida
a sensação de fracasso e todos os
sentimentos e medos que ela me trazia o
maior deles talvez fosse o que as
pessoas iriam pensar o que as pessoas
iriam dizer no entanto no momento em que
entreguei a chave de volta da
construtora aconteceu algo surpreendente
tem gente sente derrotada fracassada
como imaginava que ia ficar eu me senti
extremamente 10 sente extremamente leve
o que eu percebi que eu estava me
libertando de boa parte da ilusão de
sucesso que eu vinha sustentando até
então e do quanto eu vinha exigindo de
mim para manter aquela imagem
e se alguém jogou fracassado por isso
ninguém ligou para dizer aquele era um
medo que possa existir dentro de mim
vi então que era hora de transformar
aquele aspirador de pó na draga era hora
de fazer a limpeza daquele lago remexer
aquele sentimento é verdade escondida
toda a aparência daquelas águas salma de
sujo minha vida então começou a mudar
fui passo-a-passo questionando a
verdadeira motivação por trás de tudo
aquilo que eu havia conquistado fosse
através do consumo ou do próprio sucesso
profissional e descobrir a verdade muito
dolorosa
descobri que boa parte das coisas eu
havia feito pelo medo de não ser amado
meu filho meu desejo de ser cada vez
mais bem sucedida esconde uma
necessidade de ser admirada e
reconhecida pelos meus pais e que esse
desvio que isso também esconde uma
grande dúvida e enfim segurança sobre a
minha própria capacidade
percebi que eu sabia muito pouco sobre a
sustentabilidade da qual tanto falava
que o consumo exagerado as escolhas
inconscientes as dívidas que contraíra
para melhorar a nossa vida material e
até as escolas para que eu escolhi a
pagar se viu na verdade o propósito de
esconder de mim mesma a
insustentabilidade da vida que eu tinha
escolhido viver então devagar eu fui
fazendo as mudanças uma uma passando por
um processo de encontrar o caminho de
uma vida sustentável
mas dessa vez começando por dentro eu
passei então a partir daquele momento
aduzir uma vida sustentável
eu percebi que se eu não tinha mais
necessidade todos aqueles símbolos do
sucesso talvez não precisasse mais de
tanto dinheiro
eu não precisava de tanto dinheiro
talvez não precisasse trabalhar tanto
eu tomei algumas decisões eu tomei a
decisão por exemplo sair do mundo
corporativo
ao recuperar parte do tempo que eu havia
vendido para ter sucesso
eu comecei a restabelecer vínculos e
relações que eu tinha perdido ao longo
do caminho
eu comecei então a fazer a minha própria
comida a cuidar da casa levar meus
filhos à escola a a cuidar do meu corpo
do lixo a contar com postar os resíduos
orgânicos da minha casa
comecei a procurar saber quem eram os
produtores do bairro que fazia o que
produzimos alimentos que a gente gostava
de consumir ou seja eu entendi
finalmente que a sustentabilidade que eu
me propunha llosa por meio do trabalho
não era um lugar para onde estava indo
mais um lugar que estava criando e que
esse lugar começado em mim e que ele só
existiria na minha vida na vida das
pessoas com quem elas
na vida da minha comunidade e do planeta
a partir da minha própria experiência
bem se eu pudesse resumir todo esse
processo eu resumiria na seguinte
pergunta quais são as nossas verdadeiras
necessidades porque o custo de não
reconhecer as nossas necessidades muitas
vezes até de não conhecer é que nós
deixamos de perceber aquilo que nós
precisamos de verdade começamos a
desejar coisas que aparentemente e
momentaneamente podem suprir lá e quais
são as nossas necessidades como seres
humanos nós precisamos de alimento água
ar descanso abrigo expressão sexual
harmonia ordem pa diversão respeito
segurança emocional encorajamento
apreciação amor apoio significado
celebração escolha se observar nos
anúncios na tv por trás do modelo mais
moderno de celular ou do carro do ano
como esse de 1969 um pouco de
consciência nós conseguimos identificar
ali as necessidades humanas e universais
escondida sobre a ciência da publicidade
nesse caso por exemplo bom mesmo é ser
minoria talvez haja uma necessidade de
apreciação o que aconteceria se então
todos nós tivéssemos consciência dessas
necessidades do qual o lugar pode ser a
sensação de felicidade ao preenchê los
dessa forma é bom as mudanças na minha
vida mudar o meu trabalho também de
executiva da sustentabilidade ou seja de
alguém que pretende executar a
sustentabilidade como algo externo eu me
transformei numa conspiradora de um novo
paradigma
por meio dessas definições do roberto
crema me inspirando nela roberto crema o
rebelde é aquele imaturo que quer mudar
o mundo na marra
ele tem problemas não resolvidos com
autoridade o pai a mãe dentro de si o
revolucionário é aquele que até possui
uma ideologia mais justa mas tem um quê
de arrogância nessa atitude de querer
transformar o mundo sem antes ter se
transformado e finalmente o conspirador
é aquele que entendeu que ele é o pedaço
de praça pública que precisa ser
transformado e que a partir dessa
transformação ele pode se tornar um
agente de transformação da realidade
conspirar significa respirar juntos em
um novo paradigma nada mais é do que o
paradigma de sustentação da vida
ora nós só podemos sustentar a vida por
meio do cuidado no momento em que eu
cuido de mídia do preenchimento das
minhas necessidades
eu posso cuidar do outro das nossas
relações e do planeta conspirar por um
novo paradigma portanto é respirar
juntos o paradigma do cuidado e hoje o
impacto que estou gerando no mundo é o
mágico que pareça o impacto que eu
sonhava na minha infância
meu trabalho agora inspirar e apoiar
pessoa a trilhar o caminho da
sustentabilidade desde bem porque eu
acredito que todos nós podemos fazer
diferente a partir da nossa própria
transformação e para concluir eu quero
usar propor uma pequena mudança no
conceito de sustentabilidade amplamente
aceito que as nossas necessidades
humanas e universais sejam a base do
nosso desenvolvimento e não com os
nossos desejos de consumo
quem sabe assim nós possamos almejar a
celi cidade como medida do
desenvolvimento e não o produto interno
bruto porque o que eu aprendi nesse
processo é que a sustentabilidade ela
não é a meta a ser alcançada ela é o
caminho que a gente precisa percorrer
para reencontrar a nossa conexão com a
terra e com todos os outros seres
humanos e não humanos
eu entendo que nós estamos vivendo um
momento de profundas transformações uma
mudança de paradigma realmente nós temos
diante de nós o desafio
fazer desse planeta que é a nossa casa
um lugar viável impossível para 7
bilhões de pessoas
9 bilhões de pessoas até 2050
talvez a resposta para esse desafio e
seja aquela velha frase do grande sendo
a mudança que nós queremos ver no mundo
não vamos sair pela tangente
obrigada